la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue vitryat pour le groupe l'est
républicain
mais merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question ça va
s'adresser à monsieur le ministre
alain vidalies secrétaire d'état chargé
des transports de la mer et de la pêche
concerne notre dame des landes
nous avons eu à loire-atlantique des à
dist nous avons aux airs de beatniks
violent quand il le faut déterminer
quand ils savent qu'ils font peur à la
gauche ait peur au pouvoir
rappelons-nous les événements violents
d'il ya deux ans sur les 1600 hectares
de la zad déjà acheté pour le projet de
cet aéroport les conséquences sont
encore bien visibles
la route départementale numéro 2 181 est
fermé depuis deux ans cas unique en
europe depuis l'ex yougoslavie
seras tu aimerais ouverte un jour une
présence humaine est bien là 100 à 200
personnes installées dans des abris de
fortune
quelques fermes occupées comme une
cohabitation qui s'est installée avec
des agriculteurs réfractaires au projet
une économie dite et au progrès une
économie dite nouvelle s'y développent
tout cela sous les yeux des habitants
des communes proches scandalisé par
cette zone de non droit on a
l'impression que ce laisser-aller va
fixer une population pour longtemps les
élus parlent d'un laxisme avérée des
services de l'état et pendant ce temps
là les sommes fabuleuses sont tout
l'intérêt général sont dépensés à
proximité de l'aéroport actuel nantes
atlantique comme si le transfert était
acquis déplacement du marché d'intérêt
national de nantes le seconde france
après régis coup plus de 70 millions
d'euros projet de construction sur le
même site d'un nouveau chu qui dans
l'axé des pistes de l'actuel aéroport à
moins de trois kilomètres du but de de
la propriété ne pourra peut-être pas
ouvrir dans les conditions normales
compte tenu des nuisances vraisemblable
évaluation un petit milliard d'euros les
chiffres du développement de transports
aériens sont pourtant sans appel et
légitime totalement cette infrastructure
nationale
et je le rappelais 3 doublement préfet
prévisible du trafic dans les trois dans
les quinze ans 31000 avions à construire
d'ici 2030 par les deux plus grands
constructeurs à ercé à votre question
monsieur le ministre de question allez
vous rendent possible la circulation sur
les routes autour de la trame de landes
comptez vous un jour sortir du dilemme
politique dans lesquelles vous enferme
vos alliés verts pour qu'enfin les
travaux commencent sachant vous n'avez
plus guère les moyens de revenir en
arrière merci merci monsieur criard pour
vous répondre la parole et à monsieur
alain vidalies la parole monsieur le
ministre
merci merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur le projet a fait
l'objet d'une large concertation
publique et la commission du dialogue
qui a été mise en place en 2012 a
confirmé le bien-fondé de la réalisation
de ce futur aéroport tout en suggérant
des études complémentaires pour un
diagnostic partagé et des pistes
d'amélioration deux études ont ici été
réalisées l'une sur les nuisances
sonores dans l'hypothèse d'un maintien
de l'aéroport actuel elle conclut que le
nombre d'habitants soumis aux bruits
passerait à près de 80000 l'autre sur un
réaménagement de l'aéroport actuel
le coût des travaux pour permettre le
développement de l'aéroport de nantes
dans le respect des règles de sécurité
serait proche de celui du futur aéroport
sans réduire les nuisances
ces études sont soumises un débat
contradictoire
toutes les hypothèses données
méthodologie de ces études ont été
expliqués et rendue publique et le
gouvernement est attaché à respecter
scrupuleusement les réglementations
applicables à ce projet plus de 50
recours déposés par les opposants ont
déjà été rejetée par la justice
par ailleurs des mesures de compensation
environnementales ont été précisées et
complétées et des prescriptions
exigeante et ambitieuse au maître
d'ouvragé ont été inscrits dans les
arrêtés loi sur l'eau et espèce protégée
pour garantir l'efficacité
de ces prescriptions l'état s'est imposé
une obligation de résultat le projet de
l'aéroport et conduit dans le respect du
droit
dans un souci de transparence et de
dialogue le gouvernement n'a pas
l'intention de débuter les travaux avant
le jugement des recours juridiques
actuellement déposés qui sont tous en
voie de finalisation
concernant les comportements sur la zone
tous les actes délictueux commis par les
opposants radicaux à l'aéroport dès lors
qu'ils sont portés à la connaissance des
forces de l'ordre font l'objet de
procédures judiciaires
merci monsieur l'uni